well hi everybody uh and welcome to the
rouge
um the home of the uh electric
f-150 lightning mr president we are so
honored you could be with us today
to share in this really important moment
you know you've always had a deep
appreciation for our industry
and the men and women who power it and
you understand
that building things in this country
matters
the rouge is one of the world's great
industrial centers but it's more than a
factory
for over a century it's where
generations of workers have proudly
built
some of the most important vehicles and
built
better lives for their families
you know there was a time when ford
executives thought this was a relic
of a bygone era and they wanted to close
the entire rouge site
but i decided no let's turn the nation's
biggest brownfield site
into the greenest plant in the country
today i'm proud that the rouge has been
transformed into a state-of-the-art
manufacturing site
middle and it's awesome
for more than 44 years the f-150 has
been the backbone of work
across our country it's been a trusted
icon
for generations now we're
revolutionizing it
for a new generation as we progress
toward a zero emission
and digital future for both ford
and the american auto industry the f-150
lightning
represents a defining moment as it as it
ushers in
a cleaner future for our country
we can't wait to share the whole story
with the world
tomorrow night mr president
as you work toward a future that's more
sustainable
and made in america ford is right there
with you
we appreciate your commitment to
rebuilding the nation's roads and
bridges
establishing a network of electric
vehicle chargers
and investing in the kind of clean
energy manufacturing
that we are pioneering right here at
ford
this company is and always has been
built for america we make more vehicles
and employ more uaw hourly workers in
the u.s
than any other automaker today the rouge
employs 7 300 people
and we'll continue that commitment by
creating an additional 500 jobs
for at the electric vehicle center
this is the power of american
manufacturing
and the power of the men and the women
of the rouge
and of the ford family it's how we
redefine the future by staying true to
our values
and those values are why we were able to
pivot so quickly last year
to produce ventilators mass and
respirators
during the pandemic thank you mr
president for coming here today
and for your unwavering support of our
industry
in our incredible workforce
now i know the secret service may not
let you drive yourself
but if you can win them over you're
always welcome to take the f-150
lightning for a spin
and i promise you it's going to give
your corvette a run for its money
and now i'd like to call up a friend of
mine
and a great leader rory gamble president
of the uaw
thank you
[Music]
hello hello and i want to thank all of
you for being here today to share this
great accomplishment
with the brothers and sisters of the
dearborn truck plant
you guys
i want to acknowledge some of our
friends who have come with us today
the local 600 president bernie ricky
uh steve zimmerman who is representing
the uaw ford department
my dear friend and all of our friend
region 1a director
chuck browning and his a.d laura
dickerson
[Applause]
and we have a host of congress folks and
all kind of folks who have joined us on
this journey
so many times i can't list them all but
i would be remiss if i didn't
acknowledge
uh congresswoman debbie dingle
congresswoman brendan lawrence
congresswoman rashida lead
that that's that's my that's my you know
rashida to leave is kind of like the
moral compass you know
when it's something that we need to get
set right on i when the phone ring i
just said
lord have mercy here comes
but but she's a dear friend so thank you
rasheeda
all right it is this is a great day for
me
um we i've been a part of local 600 my
entire career
i was elected officer at the local along
with bernie ricky
pretty much when the rude site you know
they were calling for our demise
there were those in the company that
called this a museum
and they referred to the officers of the
local as the curators of the museum
we were part of negotiations called the
rules viability agreement
which bill ford championed
very very very very aggressively
at the time we were pretty much dying on
the vine
now what you see before you are the
efforts
of great teamwork between the uaw and
ford motor company
this is what teamwork can accomplish
building world-class vehicles that meet
the needs of america
and are ready for the challenges that
the new technology
would bring for us all and at the same
time
protecting good paying american jobs
and the workers have the right to
unionize and have a voice in the
workplace
i want to thank this great uaw for team
my brothers and sisters when i worked
here it was a d.a.p
uh at the time we had a little saying
you know
when you get on your job get your head
down and your ass up
my brothers and sisters at a dearborn
truck plant you have accomplished that
and you set an example for many to
follow god bless you all
do all that you can
[Music]
keep
me
when you believe in things
[Music]
please welcome united auto workers
member from the ford dearborn truck
plant
angela powell
oh
[Music]
good afternoon everyone
my name is angela powell and i work here
at the dearborn truck plant
as a forklift operator and i can't
believe that i am standing here today
it is truly an honor
and i am deeply humble to present to you
today the president of the united states
[Applause]
i feel so blessed a president
who in just over a hundred days
have gotten our pandemic under control
a president in just over a hundred days
left no american families behind
in his rescue plan a president
who supports workers like me and my
sisters and brothers
each and every day by passing the pro
act
and an infrastructure bill that will
build our future
in factories like this one here in the
historic
rouge a president
who understands that in order for the
future
to work for us all american workers
can't be forgotten
or left behind in this transition for
the future
future jobs need to be well-paying
union jobs with benefits and joe biden
gets that
having a good paying union job
has meant a lot to me and my family
and most of all a president who
loves the cars we build
a president who came here to see us
unveil the ford
f-150 lightning which we are so very
proud of
it is my pleasure on behalf of my
sisters and brothers
here at the dearborn truck plant local
600
and all of uaw members
to introduce to you the president of the
united states
joseph r biden
[Music]
my name is joe biden and i'm a car guy
i got please sit down i got through high
school and college and law school
because my dad ran an agency
and uh i'm delighted to be here
i want to say something else up front
i'm standing here because about 180
years ago when i first got elected to
the senate
gov
the uaw elected me
[Applause]
we used to have the highest percentage
of auto workers of any state in the
nation because we had a small workforce
and two giant plans plus mopar and a few
other things going on
so i want to thank you look and i want
to thank
a good friend of mine michigan governor
gretchen whitmer as my mother would say
gretchen
god love you dear you've got a backbone
like a ramrod
you got a brain as big as anybody in the
business and you are so
honorable i'm so delight to know you and
anything i can do
as i said to you before i'll come
campaign for you against you whichever
will help the most
and ange i want to thank angela we were
talking backstage
backstage yeah on the other side of the
truck
and uh i want to thank her very much for
being so gracious
and rory i know you're new to the labor
movement but you're doing pretty good
job
where is rory rory thank you pal
thank you thank you thank you and uh and
everyone at the uaw for being the best
auto workers in the world
you know uh and i want to thank uh bill
ford and jim farley for hosting us and
investing in our workers and in our
country we're at a great inflection
point in american history
how we handle the next four to ten years
is going to determine where we're going
to be 30 40 50 years from now it's one
of those moments in american history
this is an incredible facility
representative debbie dingle another
dear friend
i know john's looking down and he's
saying we're finally getting it done huh
you're getting it done debbie you're uh
and representative dan kildee is a good
friend representative brenda lawrence
uh and by the way be careful just say to
uh
representative slotkin she knows more
than you they may be watching you
where are you i tease her all the time
she's a great great great addition to
the congress
and rasheed talib where's rashid
i tell you what rasheed i want to say to
you that uh
i admire your intellect i admire your
passion
and i admire your concern for so many
other people
and it's my from my heart i pray that
your grandmom and family
are well i promise you i'm going to do
everything you see that they are
in the west bank you're a fighter and
god thank you for being a fighter
and andy levin know a lot of levins
and uh hayley stevens i thank you all as
well
and also want to thank mayor jim
o'reilly of dearborn for the passport
into the city thank you mr mayor
and my buddy mike duggan he is my mayor
i got i was sitting one day in the oval
with with barack obama when president
obama when i was vice president
and he looked at me like it was just
something off he said by the way i want
you to go fix detroit
i said say that again what am i going to
he said you can get anybody in the
government to go with you
you just do it first call i made was
this guy
you brought it off his knees you brought
it back you're a great mayor
and you're a great friend you got a lot
of courage thank you
two great friends debbie stabenow and
gary peters who couldn't be here today
because they're back
fighting like hell fighting for this
industry and the people of the state and
for labor
labor industry federal state local
leaders all together
that's america that's best and that's
what i so admire about what bill ford's
doing here
and uh i you know i want to so
everything that
these workers this historic complex in
this state represent
is something that i hope gets modeled
around the country it's about respect
it's about dignity the dignity of work
my dad used to say
joey and i swear to god when he left
scranton when cole died my dad was not a
was he was a salesperson he wasn't a
coal miner my
great-grandpa was but he uh he said uh
he used to say when he moved to delaware
he got a lead because there were no jobs
he left us with a grandpop for
a little over a year and he commuted
back and forth from wilmington delaware
to scranton
on the weekends and we got back down to
wilmington used to say to all of us and
i was i guess then about
i was going to third grade and he'd say
joe remember i mean this sincerely
a job is about a lot more than a
paycheck
it's about your dignity it's about
respect
it's about your place in the community i
really mean this about being able to
look at your kid in the eye and say
honey it's gonna be okay
it's gonna be okay
it's not labor it's union because what
you allow people to do is hold their
heads up
make a decent living and have pride in
what they do
pride in what you build pride in what
you give this nation
and i wanted to be here today the day
before you unveil the next
generation of america's best-selling
vehicle to the entire world to
thank you thank you for showing how we
win the competition of the 21st century
you know how the future is going to be
made but it's going to be made here in
america
made in america
[Applause]
i have to say this brings me home
for more than 30 years my dad would move
to delaware managed
automobile dealerships in delaware
including the ford dealership
and man did i like that 57 ford fairlane
oh boy they ain't got nothing on the
f-150
but uh all kidding aside that's what got
me through school
and you know i doubt i'd be uh i i
i doubted that it would ever contribute
50 billion 50 billion dollars to support
about 500 000 american jobs at 150.
half the 1 million american jobs force
supports overall
like the 150 series you know i just got
a tour of the
groundbreaking electric vehicle center
here along with
uaw workers and they showed me the
technology they're using to build this
first ever fully electric
f-150 i was able to sit
in it quite frankly i let me see it so i
apologize to you and i won't see it for
tomorrow
you're gonna like it and uh
and i'd sure like to drive it um
i wonder whether or not i can lose the
secret service and go out to the track
uh but uh you all think i'm kidding
don't you
press knows i'm not look
the future of the auto industry is
electric
there's no turning back and as rory says
the american auto industry is at a
crossroads
the real question is whether we'll lead
or will fall behind in the race of the
future
or whether we'll build these vehicles
and the batteries that go in them
here in the united states rely on other
countries
whether the jobs to build these vehicles
and batteries are
good-paying union jobs with benefits
jobs that will sustain and grow the
middle class
right now china is leading in this race
make no bones about it it's a fact you
know we used to invest more research and
develop than any country in the world
and china was number eight extremely
number nine
we now are number eight and china's
number one
can't let that be sustained the future
is going to be determined are the best
minds
in the world by those who break through
new barriers
you know it has china
the largest fastest growing electrical
vehicle market
in the world the key part of the
electric vehicle is the battery
right now 80 of the manufacturing
capacity of those batteries
is done in china
so not the battery for the 150 f-150
we went down to georgia and took care of
that
it allows them to corner the market on
supplies of raw materials for those
batteries
important almost importing almost all
the
lithium 90 that comes from countries
from like
australia which lead the world and
mining these kinds of critical materials
and here's the deal it's not that
china's battery technology is that much
more innovative than anyone else's
remember our national labs in the united
states our universities our automakers
led in the development of this
technology but today
china has a bigger manufacturing scale
than all other countries
and they're using that scale to make
these batteries not just in china but
they're making them in germany
and in mexico and now exporting those
electric vehicles around the world
with sights on the american market
and they think they're going to win but
i got news for them
they will not win this race
we can't let them we have to move
fast and that's what you're doing here
when president obama and i when barack
and i were in office
that was what we're going to do remember
in 2009
the auto industry is flat on us back and
remember i got criticized by the
president because i was the auto guy
pushing well guess what
we were told that we'd never be able to
sell american-made cars at the same rate
as before
but we didn't listen we bet on you
the american auto worker we extended a
lifeline and we stepped up
saved more than a million jobs working
the auto industry we set fuel efficiency
standards
provided incentives for folks to buy
fuel-efficient vehicles
and through the recovery act we made the
largest investment in clean energy and
battery technology ever
and the big three emerged from the
crisis in a position
to sell millions of vehicles made right
here in the usa
but then the previous administration
came into office
they roll back the standards we said
rollbacks that the ford motor company
opposed
despite bipartisan support for consumer
incentives
they let the federal tax credit expire
penalizing
auto workers who are selling the most
electric vehicles at the time
they announced infrastructure week and
they announced it and announced it and
announced it and announced it
every week for four years and then do a
damn thing
didn't get the job done folks the rest
of the world is moving fast
they're moving ahead they're not waiting
for the united states of america
government labor industry working
together have to step
up and we have a playbook
that'll work we're going to set a new
pace
for electric vehicles that means
reversing the previous administration's
short-sighted rollback
of vehicle emissions and efficiency
standards
setting strong clear targets where we
need to go
it means passing the american jobs plan
to do three things
one transform our infrastructure
our infrastructure is ranked like 38 in
the world
just the united states of america for
god's sake
we're going to put americans to work
modernizing our roads our highways our
ports our airports
rails and transit systems that includes
putting ibew members and the union
workers
to work installing 50 000
charging stations along our roads and
highways
our homes and our apartments the ibew is
ready to do it and they can
two we're going to boost our
manufacturing capacity
that's why the american jobs plan
invests in new and
retooled union facilities grants
to kickstart new battery and parts
production
loans and tax credits to boost
manufacturing
of these clean vehicles that also makes
the largest investment in research and
development
in generations it's going to help
innovate
manufacture and build supply chains for
batteries and semiconductors
and small computer chips that make
electric trucks and cars
go to be even more reliant than they are
now
it matters the little things matter
we saw last night the united
states senate voted overwhelmingly to
begin
work on part of the bill that i've been
pushing
to strengthen our innovation and
infrastructure by investing in research
and development manufacturing
i don't remember the exact number but it
was pretty high there was 83 to
something in a bipartisan vote
it's a good first step
and you're members of congress here in
michigan they know the value of
manufacturing as well as anyone
and are vital in pushing forward that
bill and others
never again should we be in a situation
we face today with semiconductor
shortages
the united states can't manufacture
semiconductors
we were the beginning
you know
i think some people think i'm too uh
too proud of what the united states
always did and why i get so frustrated
only sliding but i make no apologies for
it
we know these kinds of federal
investments work
it was the defense department and nasa
that got the modern semiconductor
industry
on his feet decades ago we
started your tax dollars
our own department of energy pioneered
and transformed the battery injury when
barack and i were in office
and through the recovery act grants and
loans
battery prices dropped 80 percent
80 percent because we were looking
forward
we need that same mindset today
we have to look forward
and uh you know
we have to work to support consumers
and these fleets that means new
purchasing incentives for consumers to
buy
clean vehicles like the electric ford
150 a union made product right here in
america
but all the pieces must be made in
america
it means spurring demand by converting
the federal government's enormous fleet
of vehicles
into clean vehicles and supporting
electric transit systems
and school buses
folks when i got elected i signed an
executive order saying
we're going to buy america as president
i get to
award contracts in the area of 600 to
700 billion dollars a year
from building aircraft carriers to
railings that go in
in buildings guess what
representative kildy knows i'm not
letting a single contract
to a single company that does not
hire americans have all american parts
and has a
supply chain that is an american product
supply chain
and by the way
that's not violating any trade agreement
it's been the law since the 30s
but no one's had the courage or the
nerve to insist on it being applied
it's no violation of the world trade
organization or anything else
if we're spending american tax dollars
we're able to say buy america
but there's a lot of exception in law if
you don't have the part immediately
available at 5 10 you can go abroad and
get it
and anyone of the agency can say i can't
find it here i'm going somewhere
not anymore they got to go through the
white house not a joke
nobody can give that exception now
because there's thousands of companies
out there able to do
small companies three four 10 15 people
who can supply those pieces that they
know they can compete for them
my brother has an expression a guy named
pete mclaughlin was a great basketball
player played for providence was a good
close friend
he'd say joe you got to know how to know
you got to know how to know
we don't let the american companies know
what's available to them especially if
they're small
so we're going to have we have an office
in the facility in the white house
to let people know what's needed
and there's another thing we have in our
playbook that's going to out-compete
other nations
the biggest secret we have the american
worker not a joke
they're the finest workforce in the
world it's our ace in that deck
now i know many of you watching at home
are like the folks i grew up with in
scranton and claim on delaware
they feel left out left behind
in an economy in an industry that's
rapidly changing
i understand it i really do
but we will leave no one behind
nearly 90 percent of the jobs created in
my american jobs plan
do not require bachelor's degree
75 percent don't require a
associate's degree we're going to be
working with companies and community
colleges and technical schools and union
of apprentice and training programs
to make sure that american workers will
be prepared to compete with anyone in
the world
just like ford does with its workforce
training center here in dearborn
and when we invest in our infrastructure
we're going to buy american products
materials services for american
businesses
made in america and we'll do everything
in our power
to encourage and protect the right of
workers to unionize
and collectively bargain
i met with i think it was more than a
dozen ceos of the major fortune 500
companies
we started off and i said i want to be
clear with you
i'm a union guy and every one of them
but one
said i understand because now they're
realizing what mr ford realizes
that you are the best workers available
you're the best trained
you're the most capable and you save
overall
bottom line american jobs plan is a
blue-collar blueprint
to rebuild america a blue-collar
blueprint to build america
and we need automakers and other
companies to keep investing here in
america and not taking
our public investments to expand
electric vehicles and battery
manufacturing
production abroad we need you to deepen
your partnership with the uaw
pay good wages support communities like
dearborn across the country
we need to come together as a nation the
vice president and i
have had a number of meetings in the
oval office with republican leaders in
congress and
members of congress we believe we can
find a bipartisan deal on infrastructure
and we look forward to hearing more
details of their proposal which they're
going
to submit counter either later today or
tomorrow to me
but we made one thing clear we'll
compromise
but doing nothing is not an option
doing nothing is not an option the world
is not waiting i say for a second time
i'll conclude with this last month
i kept my commitment to convene the
leaders of the major economies around
the world from russia china india japan
the european union i convened them all i
think there are 48 or 50
heads of state presidents and prime
ministers
a meeting i hosted by the white house
one of the most consequential issues
facing the world
climate crisis and i made it clear at
the outset
as each of these folks came on what i've
long believed
when i think of the climate crisis
beyond this devastation the lives and
livelihoods and health of our very
planet
i think jobs i think
jobs when i think climate change good
paying
union job i think about the uaw workers
here today i wanted to make sure
that the world could see that there was
a consensus
that we are at an inflection point in
our history and almost
every major leader in the world spoke to
it
if we act to save the planet we can
create millions
good paying jobs generate significant
economic growth and opportunity to raise
the standard
for people not only here but around the
world
but i also wanted to put the world on
notice
america is back america
is back in the competition
for the 21st century the future will be
built
right here in america look at this plan
we're moving we're working again we're
dreaming again we're discovering again
we're leading the world again we have
shown each other in the world that
there's no
quit in america there's simply no quit
in america
and that's never ever it's every time i
have these sometimes knocked down drag
them out with heads of state
in private they'll say something i say
look
it's never been a good bet to bet
against america
never never never this is the united
states of america there's not a single
thing
i believe there's every fiber remain not
a single thing
nothing beyond our capacity when we act
together
and that's exactly what we're about to
do starting with all of you and thank
you for allowing me to be here
may god bless you and may god protect
our troops thank you
thank you thank you thank you
[Music]
i don't want you around those pretty
faces
always stand out in a crowd
but someone kicked you from the bunch
when the glass was all it took
now it's much too late for me to take
[Music]
me